[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch norbert lehmann für den
sparzwang tor von mir und das sind
unsere wichtigsten themen heute
der druck wächst der ruf nach strengeren
corona maßnahmen wird lauter merkel und
scholz laden für morgen zu einem bund
länder gipfel
ansturm auf praxen und wieder eröffnete
impfzentren auffrischungen sind gefragt
aber auch erstimpfungen nehmen wieder zu
und das leben in deutschland wird
deutlich teurer zum ersten mal so etwas
30 jahren steigt die inflationsrate auf
mehr als fünf prozent
wir brauchen umfassende kontakt
beschränkungen und zwar sofort das
fordern immer drängender viele
wissenschaftler und ärzte außerdem eine
höhere impfquote sie zeigen kein
verständnis für das zögern der politik
morgen nun wollen bund und länder
beraten währenddessen treibt die delta
variante mit wucht die vierte welle
weiter nach oben dazu kommt die sorge
vor der neuen omikron variante des
corona virus thomas reichert berichtet
es war die bislang grösste verlegung von
kovac schwerkranken 50 wurden am
wochenende aus bayern thüringen und
sachsen in andere bundesländer gebracht
einige davon auch mit militärflugzeugen
die dramatik der situation so die
experten der leopoldina würden teile der
politik nicht voll erfassen
wir brauchen sofort kontakt
beschränkungen um die viruslast die
derzeit sehr hoch in der bevölkerung ist
zu senken und wir brauchen für die
nächsten wochen leute die geimpft sind
doch zwischen union und ampel gab es
erstmal viel parteienstreit ob die
nächste ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
vorgezogen werden soll nun wollen bund
und länder schon morgen beraten das ziel
deutschlandweite regelungen
möglicherweise weitere kontakt
beschränkungen zu den maßnahmen wie
angedacht werden müssen gehört meiner
ansicht nach auch zu überlegen ob die
weihnachtsferien vorgezogen werden
müssen und die vorbereitung für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht müssen getroffen
werden es zeigt sich immer stärker dass
beispielsweise diese freizeit nahen
veranstaltungen am wochenende
beispielsweise clubs bars diskotheken
dass die also viele fälle verursachen
die dann sich auch schnell verbreiten
das müsste eigentlich geschlossen werden
im kanzleramt will die ampel schon vor
amtsübernahme einen krisenstab
einrichten er soll helfen inseln und
postern zu beschleunigen dass nun halten
alle für dringlich wir werden also die
nächsten wochen impfstoff von moderner
ausreichend haben vom montag aus meiner
sicht noch immer nicht genügend aber es
sind impfungen impfstofflieferungen die
vorgezogen werden in berlin warten sie
zudem gespannt wie morgen das
bundesverfassungsgericht über die letzte
notbremse befindet es wird ein signal
sein wie weit neue einschränkungen gehen
können
theo koll in berlin immer lauter wird
nach einer bundes notbremse berufen nach
einheitlichen regeln was tut sich da
also sollte das bundesverfassungsgericht
morgen früh die bundes notbremse aus dem
frühjahr als nicht verfassungsgemäß
beurteilen dann glaube ich hat sich eine
neuerliche notbremse erledigt sollte
dieses sogenannte viertel
bevölkerungsschutz gesetz das ja die
grundlage für weitgehende
einschränkungen war aber für rechtens
erklärt werden dann dürfte das den druck
auf die ampel vor allem auf die fdp
erhöhen weiteren und schärferen
maßnahmen zuzustimmen im moment erleben
wir ja die verfahrene situation dass
alte und neue bundesregierung und auch
die länder sich gegenseitig die
verantwortung zuschieben die
gesetzlichen möglichkeiten sind zum teil
noch nicht voll ausgeschöpft zum teil
aber auch nicht ausreichend olaf scholz
hat ja am wochenende geschrieben wir
werden alles tun was nötig ist morgen
könnte sich erweisen was er mit alles
meint dankeschön nach berlin theo koll
war das
zu den corona zahlen dabei ist zu
beachten dass sie am montag in der regel
niedriger ausfallen weil am wochenende
weniger daten übermittelt werden das rkw
meldet 29 1364 neuinfektionen binnen 24
stunden das sind
1279 weniger als vor einer woche hinzu
kamen 73 todesfälle die sieben tage
incidents steigt auf 500
52,4
diese zahlen bewirken immerhin 1 sehr
viele menschen wollen ihren schutz
auffrischen andere holen sich jetzt doch
ihre erste impfung am wochenende gab es
einen run auf wieder eröffnete
impfzentren auch viele hausärzte boten
am samstag extra impfaktionen an
660.000 menschen nutzten das vor den
praxen seit tagen das selbe bild lange
schlange wäre die welt und henriette de
maizière berichten
dreimal die woche wird die arztpraxis
zum kleinen im zentrum
sie versuchen hier so viele zu impfen
wie sie nur irgendwie schaffen in der
hausarztpraxis von sibylle katzenstein
kämpft ein team gegen die übermacht der
vierten welle
umgefallen
getrieben von der sorge um steigende
instanzen kommen viele für ihre dritte
impfung den booster großer andrang vor
der praxis in berlin-neukölln seit
sieben uhr morgens stehen die menschen
in der schlange
machen dass man die leute nicht ein zwei
stunden anstehen wenn genug impfstoff da
ist schaffen sie bis zu 500 impfungen
pro tag immer wieder auch erstimpfungen
wer sich gut aufgehoben fühle mache auch
anderen mut sich impfen zu lassen und
das sei das einzige mittel momentan
macht ihnen das eigentlich sorge
erreichen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
zwei monate standen die vier impfzentren
im saarland still jetzt machen drei
wieder auf egal ob als zweit oder
booster impfung in saarlouis sind sie
froh einen termin ergattert zu haben
[Applaus]
ich bin ehrlich spar querdenker gewesen
richter querdenker abgeschossen gehen
die medien gehen alles um letztendlich
hat mich praktisch die ganze sache hat
mich zum knicken punkt wo ich halt
einfach gedacht ich mach das jetzt aber
ich halte es schwierig einen anderen
anstecken sie beginnen mit einer stadt
zwei schichten am tag und in saarlouis
600 statt 1200 impfungen wie zu
hochzeiten impfstoff gibt es genügend
was fehlt ist personal das wichtigste
war die personalakquise
viele haben wieder andere berufe gesucht
sind in ihrer alten berufe zurückgekehrt
als die im zentrum geschlossen worden
sind ansonsten hatten die hier alles im
standby betrieb
das saarland will den impf turbo zünden
nach bremen liegt es mit einer impfquote
von 77 prozent beim imf tempo mit vorn
ich habe mich bei der incidents zahl
vorhin versprochen und sie höher gemacht
als sie ist sie liegt natürlich bei 4
152,4 ich bitte das zu entschuldigen
wie ist die impf situation in ihrem
bundesland das erfahren sie jederzeit
auf unsere zdf heute app dort gibt es
auch eine übersicht wie viele
intensivbetten aktuell in ihrem
landkreis oder ihrer stadt belegt sind
die hersteller der impfstoffe forschern
unter hochdruck daran ob ihre produkte
auch gegen omikron wirken oder ob sie
angepasst werden müssen in europa melden
immer mehr länder ansteckungen mit der
neuen virus variante und zwar nicht nur
bei reisenden aus südafrika südafrika
selbst fühlt sich durch die
reisebeschränkungen vieler länder zitat
bestraft dafür dass es die neue variante
enthüllt hat susan von lojewski hat mir
südafrika ist sauer richtig sauer darauf
dass es von einem großteil der welt
ausgesperrt wird die ein und ausreise
zumindest erschwert ist und das land nun
als herd für die omikron variante gilt
präsident rakusa findet im fernsehen
deutliche worte
diese beschränkungen sind komplett
ungerechtfertigt und diskriminieren
unser land und unsere südafrikanischen
schwester länder auf unfaire weise das
reiseverbot ist jeder wissenschaftlich
fundiert noch wird es die verbreitung
dieser variante wirksam verhindern
omikron trifft das land zu einem mehr
als ungünstigen zeitpunkt die
weihnachtsferien stehen an auch
international ist jetzt die beste
reisezeit jeder vierte südafrikaner ist
inzwischen vollständig geimpft das land
hat in den letzten zwei monaten die
impfquote fast verdoppelt die mutanten
trifft offenbar vor allem junge menschen
die sorge jetzt ist groß
niemand weiß ob die impfstoffe die auf
dem markt sind wirksam sind gegen die
variante das macht mir angst
die neue variante besonders
lebensbedrohlich für alte menschen so
die vorsitzende des ärzteverbandes noch
aber stehen die wissenschaft am anfang
die aufregung die derzeit in den medien
und weltweit verbreitet wird entspricht
nicht dem klinischen bild
und es ist nicht gerechtfertigt uns
einfach von allen reisen abzuschneiden
und südafrika einzusperren als ob wir
die varianten treiber in dem ganzen
prozess wären
tatsache ist die infektionszahlen in
südafrika steigen rasant doch sie sind
noch sehr viel niedriger als in
deutschland noch
wieder nach deutschland der tarifstreit
im öffentlichen dienst ist beendet drei
verhandlungsrunden waren nötig jetzt
steht ein kompromiss gefordert hatte die
gewerkschaft wäre die ursprünglich fünf
prozent mehr gehalt
herausgekommen ist unter anderem ein
plus von
2,8 prozent allerdings erst ab dezember
2022 obendrauf gibt's einen einmaligen
steuerfreien corona bonus von 1300 euro
nicola albrecht und dort stürmen die
körpersprache des verdi chefs spricht
bände zwar ist am mittag endlich eine
einigung da doch fünf prozent mehr lohn
wie ursprünglich gefordert sind es bei
weitem nicht das ist kein tarifergebnis
was vollständig befriedigend ist aus
unserer sicht aber es ist respektabel
das hat eindeutig starke seiten für die
angestellten etwa der hohe und schnelle
corona bonus oder im gesundheitswesen
teils deutlich höhere zulagen wie
intensiv und schichtzuschläge bis beginn
der linearen erhöhung dauert es
allerdings noch ein gutes jahr und das
bei recht langer vertrags laufzeit die
arbeitgeber am ende zufrieden heißt die
gewerkschaften trotz ebenfalls
deutlicher zugeständnisse beiden seiten
wehtut und ist meistens ein guter
kompromiss und so ist es auch in diesem
fall das dürften so manche angestellten
anders sehen jens peters etwa arbeitet
im brandenburgischen
gesundheitsministerium er hatte für
deutlich mehr protestiert seine
bewertung heute die korona prämie ist
ein kleiner anreiz ja aber die 2,8
prozent und dann gerade zum dezember
nächsten jahres erst die rettung da
hätte ich mir schon was besseres
vorgestellt der beamtenbund dbb würde
das ergebnis gern auch auf gut 2,2
millionen beamte und
versorgungsempfänger übertragen
gesamtkosten für die länder sehr sicher
im milliardenbereich
solche lohnerhöhungen sind schnell
verpufft wenn sich wie im moment die
preisspirale immer schneller dreht und
vieles teurer wird im november stieg die
inflation auf 5,2 prozent
eine ähnliche teuerungsrate gab es
zuletzt vor 29 jahren im zug der
wiedervereinigung heute sind es vor
allem die energiekosten die die
inflation nach oben treiben fragen wir
sina mainitz in frankfurt an der börse
warum greift die europäische zentralbank
da nicht ein ja weil die europäische
zentralbank ebenso wie die volkswirte
der meisten banken davon überzeugt sind
dass die preise nun nicht weiter steigen
werden dazu sagte
ezb-direktoriumsmitglied
isabel schnabel im zdf wir gehen davon
aus dass im november der höhepunkt der
inflationsentwicklung erreicht ist und
dass die inflation im kommenden jahr
wieder allmählich zurückgehen wird und
zwar in richtung unseres
inflationsziels von 2
dennoch wird vieles um uns herum teurer
verbraucher merken dass insbesondere bei
lebensmitteln dienstleistungen und bei
der energie gerade in diesem bereich
sind die preise innerhalb eines jahres
um 22 prozent angestiegen die
inflationsrate von 5,2 wird mit den
außergewöhnlichen auswirkungen und
folgen der pandemie begründet wir
stecken mittendrin in der vierten corona
welle und eine neue virusvariante macht
sich breit beides sorgt für eine menge
unsicherheit inwiefern die prognose der
ezb von einer teuerungsrate um rund zwei
prozent im sommer kommenden jahres dann
tatsächlich auch eintritt wird sich
zeigen dankeschön nach frankfurt ziehen
haben ein netz gerne in wien verhandeln
iran und westliche staaten nach langer
pause wieder über das atomprogramm des
landes die gute nachricht dabei ist wohl
das überhaupt wieder geredet wird auch
wenn kaum jemand mit einem erfolg
rechnet der westen will iran vom bau
einer atombombe abhalten die neue ultra
konservative regierung in teheran
fordert die sanktionen aufzuheben die
wirtschaft im iran leidet massiv unter
den handelsbarrieren vor allem den der
usa glück wallbott berichtet
der medizingerätehersteller kmt in
teheran beliefert iranische arztpraxen
und kliniken auf der sanktionsliste
stehen solche medizinischen gütern nicht
aber der zahlungsverkehr ist schwierig
deutsche hersteller liefern nicht mehr
die deutschen firmen reagierten am
zurückhaltendsten sie haben aus furcht
war amerikanischen sanktionen sofort
jede zusammenarbeit mit uns eingestellt
die lücke füllen jetzt vor allem
chinesische hersteller die ultra
konservativen hardliner die seit der
wahl im sommer in parlament und
regierung den ton angeben sehen sich als
opfer aggressiver
us-außenpolitik zugeständnisse beim
eigenen atomprogramm dass sie massiv
vorantreiben wollen sie nicht machen
unsere forderung ist klar die sanktionen
müssen sofort aufgehoben werden die usa
haben das abkommen verlassen sie müssen
das rückgängig machen
[Musik]
die herrschenden kleriker und
revolutionsgardisten kontrollieren
ungeachtet der sanktionen weiter
milliardenschwere firmen imperien die
öleinnahmen ins all ein luxus den
iranischen normalverdiener nicht haben
bei 50 prozent inflation und hoher
arbeitslosigkeit droht vielen die armut
sie machen dafür nicht nur amerika
verantwortlich
es gibt leute im staatsapparat die seit
20 jahren die sanktionen nutzen um
profite zu machen die wollen die
sanktionen nicht loswerden
die hoffnung auf eine rasche
verhandlungslösung im atomstreit ist
gross noch größer ist die skepsis dass
es dazu kommen wird
seit anderthalb jahren sitzt gilliam
maxwell in new york in haft sie war die
langjährige vertraute des
sexualstraftäters jeffrey epstein jetzt
hat der prozess gegen sie begonnen laut
anklage soll die 59-jährige sich
systematisch das vertrauen junger
mädchen erschlichen und es so apps team
ermöglicht haben sie zu missbrauchen
in manchen fällen sei sie auch aktiv
daran beteiligt gewesen so der vorwurf
der multimillionär apps team war 2009 10
tot in seiner gefängniszelle gefunden
worden
seit zehn wochen quillt aus dem vulkan
auf la palma die lava ein ende nicht
abzusehen im gegenteil jetzt hat sich
auf der nordostseite ein neuer schlot
gebildet und bedroht auch häuser die
bislang als relativ sicher galten was
2700 gebäude sind bereits zerstört die
neue landfläche die sich seit beginn des
ausbruchs gebildet hat liegt inzwischen
bei gut elf quadratkilometern
dreht sich gerade wieder dass trainer
ralf rangnick wird neuer coach bei
manchester united allerdings nur bis zum
ende der saison danach soll er dort als
berater arbeiten und bei hertha bsc muss
pal dardai seinen posten räumen für ihn
übernimmt tayfun korkut zunächst
befristet bis juli 2022
ja und jetzt von der trainerbank auf dem
platz gestern das spannende abendspiel
zwischen leipzig und leverkusen dass die
bayer-elf 3 2 1 gewann
leverkusen im blau sorgte in leipzig
schon in der ersten hälfte für klare
verhältnisse florian wird sind der 21
minute das 0 2 13 minuten später ließ
muss er die abi rbs abwehr alt aussehen
leverkusen zwei tore vorsprung zur pause
verdient
mitte der zweiten hälfte kam leipzig
durch andre silber 2 auf 1 2 heran zwei
minuten später aber war die spannung
schon wieder raus jeremy frempong
gestellt mit dem ersten bundesliga tor
den alten abstand für ihn freuen wir uns
speziell das ist so ein lustiger junge
mit einem riesigen potenzial und das war
schon auch entscheidend für die
schlussphase in der tabelle leverkusen
dritter leipzig achter haben
und alle partien und alle tore dieses 13
bundesligaspieltags können sie sich noch
einmal ganz in ruhe bei uns anschauen
wie gewohnt online ausführlich
zusammengefasst bei zdf heute.de und in
der zdf- heute- app
rekord europameister timo boll hat ein
stück tischtennis geschichte geschrieben
als ältester medaillengewinner bei einer
wm der 40-jährige in roth traf heute
nach dem halbfinale von houston auf den
21 jahre jüngeren schwedin trills möhre
gott und lieferte sich ein spektakuläres
duell am ende verlor der düsseldorfer
knapp mit drei zu vier sätzen und musste
sich zum zweiten mal in seiner karriere
mit wm bronze zufrieden
ja auch ohne spitzenspieler alexander
schwere haben die deutschen tennis
herren das viertelfinale im davis cup
erreicht wie zuvor beim überraschenden
erfolg gegen serbien sicherte auch gegen
gastgeber österreich wieder das doppel
in weiß den sieg kevin krawietz und tim
pütz gewannen souverän mit 6 2 3 6 zu 4
gegen oliver marach und philipp oswald
deutschland trifft morgen in innsbruck
auf großbritannien und bei einem
deutschen sieg wäre das der erste
halbfinaleinzug im davis cup seit 14
jahren das wäre schon was und jetzt noch
was was für manche klingt wie ein
schöner traum schneesturm in england
drei nächte lang eingeschneit im pop mit
60 gästen und einer coverband
schlafplätze gab es reichlich essen auch
bier habe sie allerdings erst nach drei
uhr nachmittags ausgeschenkt sagt die
wirtin angeblich waren einige gar nicht
mal so froh dass heute die straße zum
pub geräumt wurde
schnee und regen glätte und viel wind
garstige wetter wetteraussichten kommen
gleich von katja honnefer christian
sievers freut sich auf sie im heute
journal um viertel vor zehn und wir
freuen uns wenn sie morgen wieder dabei
sind alles gute ihnen und einen schönen
rahmen noch chips
[Musik]
guten abend heute gab es häufig straßen
glätte durch schnee durch regen auch
durch gefrierenden nieselregen und auch
jetzt in der nacht liegen die
temperaturen im glätte bereich sie
sinken auf plus 2 bis minus 5 grad am
kältesten wird es am alpenrand dort
schneit es auch noch am längsten in der
zweiten nachthälfte beginnt es hier von
nordwesten kräftig zu regnen bei einem
starken bis stürmischen westnordwest
tritt morgen früh stellen sie sich auf
blätter 1 zwischen der eifel den
nordhessischen bergland aber auch hier
im nördlichen brandenburg in mecklenburg
vorpommern und auch in bayern diese
schneewolken ziehen im laufe des tages
weiter nach südosten da es aber von
nordwesten schon wieder milder wird geht
der schnee in den westlichen
mittelgebirgen wieder in regen über in
den östlichen mittelgebirgen und auch in
süddeutschland wird der schnee durch den
starken bis stürmischen wind verweht
wenn der schnee in den alpen ankommt
kann sich hier am nachmittag in
norddeutschland schon mal wieder kurz
die sonne zeigen die temperaturen liegen
morgen am alpenrand nur so bei null bis
drei grad deutlich milder wird es im
nordwesten bei acht bis zehn grad am
mittwoch wird es noch eine spur milder
es setzt tauwetter ein und danach sinken
die temperaturen am freitag liegen sie
nur noch um 0 grad guten abend